bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv dans
ce cadre exceptionnel qui est le théâtre
plein air de saint-gilles
aujourd'hui nous allons à la rencontre
d'artistes est précisément de musiciens
qui vont faire vivre le festival total
jazz rencontre jean célestin enchanté
michael ont chanté sais pas merci alors
jean célestin
oui donc les saxophonistes comment t'es
venue cette passion pour le jazz
en fait pour le jazz déjà j'ai une base
classique donc avec une base classique
déjà c'est plus solide on va dire et
après j'ai voulu m'orienter un peu vers
d'autres styles de musique et le jazz
c'est ng koala basé sur l'improvisation
et ça m'intéressait beaucoup de cette
musique là donc j'ai pris des cours
j'ai fait mes études en métropole à
bordeaux ossiam donc c'est là que je
suis tombé amoureux de cette musique là
jazz et musique tu sur leur propriété à
dire voir la rue du jazz fusion
voilà tio avec aussi des sonorités
locales voilà c'est comment on fait pour
accorder un peu tous ces gens là ont
fait mes origines vu avec
la réunion le maria donc c'est une
musique voilà un au niveau rythmique
c'est vraiment une bonne base donc je me
suis orienté vers ça pour le pour le
style
le style m'a donc mais composent sont
basés sur le rythme maloya et après au
dessus joué par dessus je mets des
sonorités on va dire un peu plus jazzy
avec des accords un peu plus recherchés
voilà d'accord alors tu travaille
beaucoup avec d'autres artistes de la
réunion à la bri et qu'est ce qu'on peut
y arriver juste un mouvement musical
local qui prend un peu tous ses
influences et qui fait on va agir
un jazz atypique oui bien sûr il ya ça
beaucoup
donc c'est un groupe groupe précurseur
dans ce style là après il ya aussi mes
10 gbe bon j'ai l'occasion de jouer avec
aussi il ya dix ans donc ça fait
maintenant près de dix ans qu'on
travaille ensemble
donc voilà d'accord donc le festival un
total case oui c'est un festival pour un
public averti
pour ceux qui veulent découvrir cette
musique oui c'est un événement on va
dire incontournable pour des artistes
comme bien sûr parce que déjà on n'a pas
trop l'occasion aussi de de pouvoir
s'exprimer dans ce style de musique à la
réunion donc à voir ce festival
donc c'est vraiment une aubaine quoi et
c'est on va dire c'est un rendez vous
particulier c'est à dire aussi de
rencontrer d'autres artistes qui n'est
pas forcément l'occasion de jouer
ensemble
voilà voilà les scénes se sert aussi de
salle pour avoir d'autres influences
bien sûr c'est en fait c'est un échange
aussi
donc comme je joue aussi avec plusieurs
groupes
nous on joue on jouera le 24 avril donc
le ça s'appelle blue son idée c'est à
l'école franco chinoises donc on joue à
17 heures mais il y aura aussi de deux
autres groupes
après donc dont jean clottes m et il ya
aussi ça ne risque qu'une aussi
également donc ces gens là on se connaît
luxe et voilà la réunion et petits donc
on se connaît entre nous quoi donc
l'occasion de venir découvrir voilà
l'occasion de venir découvrir ce style à
jazz maloya
voilà voilà bien cette musique là est
basé voilà sur un thème mais aussi sur
l'improvisation
l'interaction avec que les musiciens
voilà donc un moment à découvrir voilà
de venir dormir ici
merci a bientot avant